hello Kiana Why didn't it work out
between us
[ __ ]
I did
more and then when the follow through
came up you were like you know how the
DJ scratch as a record yeah I mean
that's what I saw when I looked at my
bank account it says
I've been off more than I could too good
God this girl wants how much money from
me what do you want to know my situation
for you trying to get back with me I
came into some money and I think I might
be able to afford to hang out with you
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
date so tell us brother uh you on the
cut video right
all right and so basically they brought
you on to talk about some of your dating
experience they asked you to call one of
your exes right
yes okay okay so so give us give us the
backstory because that call was a bit
wild so I feel like I'll just let you
tell the whole story
okay so I feel like a lot of guys have
been in the business I was right
right like orange drink or none of that
my homeboy best friend hits me and he's
like yo I got this awesome
that where she at it's like she lives in
Atlanta so I link up with her so we go
to the Atlanta aquarium
brother don't you ever in your life go
to the Atlanta aquarium for no damn
thing do you hear me
first of all there's no prices listed
anywhere at all
experience that you went through
I'm talking about they walk Penguins
through the lobby in little tuxedos hey
and if you go to the penguin show at the
end they're like that was 92 dollars
[Music]
27 for a burger so I take her we're
there we go Penguins we go to get food
she's like let me get a burger let me
get chicken strips let me get fries let
me get a soda I'm like normally that's
not exorbitant
in this particular situation it was like
223 for food
I basically am after this nice little
day day looking at my receipt like
you ain't even finished reading it and
you already know you [ __ ]
Simply Having Sex prices right here like
this is the type of money I spend on an
escort
so I'm like listen and I try to take you
know you don't want to show that that
hurt you you know
I'm like okay
parking Park is 30 years okay so we go
in she knows from some other restaurant
that's above the open air restaurant we
go up this little ramp thing and we're
in
I mean but
they brought out a whole plate and in
the middle was like
a luxurious chicken nugget s
they got the squiggly sauce on there
ain't it crazy the more empty your plate
is the more it's gold cost you
so she she's the one that decided where
to go
I'm like this looks cool she's like
let's go up to this place up here I'm
like oh okay and she's the one that that
that that decided to go to the aquarium
as well
but she been to all these places she's
the one picking where we gonna go and
then you don't got no number on it
enough money that I'm out here breaking
even on my whole trip I'm like something
needs to happen emotionally and mentally
or physically where I feel like all of
this was working this man said her
mostly just say you trying to [ __ ] why
you capping
I mean
[Laughter]
spiritually emotionally like [ __ ] you
want some [ __ ]
everybody
else and you
Innovation it had a mental breakthrough
where you're like oh wow yeah I should
look at that differently okay well so
what was this conversation me either so
yeah
it's basically just kind of like goes
through like I got a little distance and
my best friend
we'll just call her hmm right and I'm
like uh well I'm several hundred dollars
out I don't know her any better and I've
had the smallest chicken sandwich I've
ever seen in my life chicken night
whatever that was
Fritter uh in my life so you know I'm
just gonna kind of fall back yeah but
hold on Nate yeah the question was
call your ex
and ask why I didn't found out you
didn't even go out with the girl that
was not even old fish out why did you
choose to call her and they knew that
when I called because I called a
different action she was like I don't
feel comfortable talking about why so I
was like all right uh that makes a lot
more sense they wanted that juice
so call someone spicy
would be about that smoke now I know the
girl is delusional and thinks that
that's normal for uh first second or
first weekend of hanging out I mean in
Atlanta it might be but it's not in
Atlantis
call her up and uh and you have to give
the disclaimer like listen I'm doing
this foreign
with my best friend on three-way and was
like yeah why did this fool call me and
say like I cost too much money and
that's why
was like well how much money did he
spend I was like for a damn near a band
he's like oh
um yeah that'd be why yeah
I apologize brother for hooking you up
with her if she was just gonna be
basically at the ATM when she punching
your pen in I was like yeah hold up when
he said that makes sense what did she
say to that
I mean she's one of those girls that's
like I am worth it of course she'll
spend that kind of money I might
presence is worth that kind of like a
baby girl uh
uh so one you gotta go somewhere else
that's you and that's basically what
happened I was like look I can't do it
and so what we saw on the video was like
a picture of her yeah that was quick
they didn't spend too much time on your
story so it was really interesting we
wanted to figure out what that 700 was
about yeah because I said something was
a lot and you sound like you almost felt
bad for not being able to afford her I'm
like no that [ __ ] sound crazy so now I
understand a lot better
say my part they had her looking like
the hero so much he gonna punch me I'm
like okay
um it really well somebody that's the
editing eh yeah that's the editing but
to my point of view it really started
like she was an ex-worker yeah yeah
actually she was an escort at one point
because I mean if you go on a date and
you she like you ain't got the cash to
form me and you say they cut to uh
uh next time you get something not get
700 700 out so she I don't think she
looked like all people everybody was
like X worker yeah which is fine now you
were tricking yeah
but they also
they asked for that too
it depends what type you're getting
that's true
but yeah is there anything any other
notes you want to put on the story or
anything like that
yeah
so now I am all in uh watching and
catching and watching everything
and then also shout out to the viewers
that have been blowing on my social
media up being like yo they want to talk
to me
it's all right that's good that's
something definitely gonna be on you and
I after this I also want to say you run
a club right I believe in Seattle
Washington and it's the biggest black
owned comedy club in the United States
okay we might have passed by yeah can
you say the name of the club
hey ah
it doesn't matter all right yeah yeah
we'll flip it we'll flip it in the
editing but this is what I say man
listen we'll put a link to your socials
and all that stuff in uh down below so
anybody's watching if you guys want to
go farm go make sure you do that but we
appreciate you coming on brother
all right please yes there you guys have
that story that's wild
that's wild I mean y'all listen the
friend gotta hold an L for setting him
up with that girl yeah because you
should have know what type of mission
she was when you set her up you can't
just be like I got a nice girl nice girl
don't mean just nice in the face she
could be nice in the face and a whole
ass crazy [ __ ] you understand what I'm
saying yes so you have to understand
what the hell you're getting your
friends into she and guys all I tell
y'all choose the way you're going for
the first date most of the time all
right and if she gonna choose let her
know to tell you where so you can look
up the place so you make sure you're
properly dressed for it or whatever it
might be because I ain't let nobody take
me nowhere fancy crazy expensive like
that especially if it's for me to pay no
if I'm paying I'm telling you where
we're going yeah that's not that's not
that's not the thing we're not doing no
Kinder Surprise I'm not popping over the
[ __ ] uh 700 no no no that's crazy
that's not a Kinder surprise that's a
Kinder